[Musique]
oh mon pierrot eux je vais te dire là on
va passer à une autre ambiance
totalement parce que j'ai vraiment quand
je te disais que j'avais une surprise
pour toi c'est une énorme surprise
c'est sa première terry c'est la seule
télé qu'elle a bien voulu faire pour
nous ce soir
elle voulait de voir absolument et de
faire passer un message
elle est avec nous ce soir nous demande
d'accueillir je vais aller la chercher
quelqu'un t'a pas vu depuis longtemps
aux pierrots c'est melissa leo
[Applaudissements]
et
il
à mon pierrot rien parce que mélissa un
message quand j'ai pensé j'y ai pensé
ouais pourrait venir mais lui ne voudra
jamais et bah allez voir les lis ça
merci d'être là vous êtes un amour il a
dit tout ce que je voulais dire tout à
l'heure mais bon on dit mais c'était mon
coeur
il est magnifique mais ni sa merci il
est là je suis là aujourd'hui c'est
grâce à elle et à ma mère je sais vous
le dites d'en livrer votre mère votre
maman aussi qu'on embrasse temps le
s'appelle commandes et marie claire
marie claire pour lui fait des gros
bisous mais ils savent où les faire un
petit bisou aperçoit trois vous avez
accepté cette émission doucement parce
que chez vous avez tous refusé déjà
c'est lui moi je suis très mal à l'aise
chez le traiteur regardez vous n'êtes
pas même animatrice de l'émission voyons
certains de mes aises tomber ça et et
surtout c'était surtout pour dire que
moi certes j'ai fait ça pour pierre mais
beaucoup beaucoup de femmes beaucoup
d'accompagnement fait ça aussi et que
c'est très dur et et que c'est surtout
lui qui s'est battu mais il avait besoin
de vous et vous avez été formé a voulu
faire un petit bisou subway est
éclairant vous souhaite beaucoup
beaucoup de bonheur il est doux ça je
suis vraiment je voulais vous dire je
suis très très touché que vous soyez
venu dans touche pas à mon poste ce soir
c'est fait pour te remercier pour le nom
que tu as fait à jean-yves tient
beaucoup à coeur parce qu'ils souffrent
beaucoup la lui annoncer qu'il allait
rester un an de plus à l'hôpital et du
coup on a pu acheter deux appareils pour
l'aider à la rochette son genre ils se
sentent moins en moins comme des
inutiles et tout ça et c'est très dur
mais on a fait des gros
bisous à jean yves et on le soutient et
on la chance à et pierre ne t'a pas les
tapas lâché je peux te dire que pierre
et s'est battu pour jean yves et pire tu
es vraiment un type formidable ont-elles
fort merci d'avoir un téléfilm permet la
deuxième mi temps
témoignages et monteiro trouve
maintenant dans le canal football club
on t'aime vraiment fort c'est vraiment
quelqu'un connait on tâchera la nuque et
merci monteiro d'amour merci merci merci
merci mille sa merci enfermée série ben
ali c'est quoi
faites moi un cycliste un petit kiff
tous les deux à vous dites au revoir ce
soir vous dites qu'on se retrouve demain
et que vous annoncez guest my edge avec
jean luc lemoine les deux allées est
franchement des pierres et mélissa merci
encore une fois à tous pour tout votre
amour mode mais c'est aux messages de
soutien qu'ils nous ont beaucoup aidés
vraiment maintenant on va passer un truc
un peu plus rigolo oui avec jean luc qui
lui aussi m'a beaucoup soutenu j'aime
fois on t'aime mon pire ont versé